The country just held the most important presidential
election in its history.
A field of 13 candidates was narrowed down
to two for the final vote.
Fernando Haddad represented the leftist Workers’
Party, which has been in power for much of
the past two decades.
He garnered just under 45% of the vote.
Far-right candidate Jair Bolsonaro, who won
55% of the vote, has been elected Brazil’s
next President, marking a
dramatic shift in the country’s politics.
That’s because Bolsonaro is a longtime congressman
who is known for his ultra conservative and
deeply offensive rhetoric.
His rhetoric has sparked widespread protests
and outrage.
It became so bad that at a campaign
rally, the candidate was stabbed by a man
claiming he was “on a mission from God.”
But, despite the backlash, Bolsonaro drew huge crowds to his rallies and skyrocketed
to the top of the polls.
So how did this relatively unknown congressman
garner so much support?
And what does that mean for Brazil’s democracy?
Brazil hasn’t been a democracy for long.
The country was ruled by a military regime
from 1964 to 1985. It was an era marked by violence,
torture, exile, and censorship.
It was during this military regime that Jair
Bolsonaro began his career as an army captain.
When the regime fell in 1985 and Brazil became
a democracy, Bolsonaro entered politics as
a staunch far-right conservative; eventually
becoming a congressmen for Rio de Janeiro.
He served seven terms in congress but remained
controversial because of his extremist remarks.
And he continued to show an affinity for the
military dictatorship.
Just look at the photos in his congressional
office.
The portraits on the wall are presidents from
Brazil’s military regime.
As a presidential candidate, Bolsonaro didn’t change.
He openly calls called for bringing back some
of the military regime’s tactics.
In fact, Bolsonaro has picked a retired army general
as his running mate who has openly suggested
that a military coup could be a possibility.
This time though, the pro-military message struck a chord.
For many Brazilians, particularly the young
voters in Bolsonaro's base, the military regime’s
brutality has faded into history.
Instead, Bolsonaro’s praise of the armed
forces has resonated with his supporters at
a time when crime has been soaring in the
country.
In 2016, Brazil’s homicide rate was nearly
six times that of the US.
In a country that shares borders with some
of the biggest cocaine producing countries
in the world, much of Brazil’s violence
stems from drug gang rivalries.
Mismanagement of public security funds by
government officials has left police in the
country underpaid and underprepared to deal
with the mounting violence.
Bolsonaro’s pro-military stance has made
him “a champion of law and order”.
For many, even though his rhetoric calls back
to a brutal dictatorship; Bolsonaro is seen
as a solution for a country in crisis.
But Brazil’s crisis isn’t just about homicides.
The country is still reeling from the biggest
corruption scandal in its history.
And Bolsonaro has capitalized on that too.
“For weeks, Brazil has been consumed by allegations
of corruption and bribery at the highest level
involving politicians and business leaders.”
A massive corruption investigation, known
as Operation Car Wash uncovered a money laundering
scheme that funneled billions into the pockets
of politicians -- including members of major
political parties.
Bolsonaro seized the opportunity to position
himself as a political outsider and promised
to end corruption.
Here he is leading protests against Dilma
Rousseff, Brazil's president during the scandal.
He lashed out at the Worker’s Party, that
Rousseff belonged to, and whose members had
been prosecuted for corruption.
Bolsonaro was actually one of the pivotal
votes for Rousseff’s impeachment in 2016,
when he openly dedicated his vote to an army
colonel accused of widespread torture and
murders during Brazil’s dictatorship:
The corruption scandal also helped Bolsonaro
by removing his strongest opponent.
“Convicted for corruption, the man better
known as “Lula” was forced to bow out
of October’s presidential race.”
In September [2018], ex-President Lula
da Silva who was in jail for corruption, was
banned from running in the presidential race
Even from jail, Lula was polling far above
any other presidential candidate.
But when Lula was officially barred from the
race, Bolsonaro soared in the polls.
His final opponent in the presidential race,
Fernando Haddad, belongs to the same party
as Lula, but he didn't drawn didn’t draw
the same level of support.
In part because of the increase in crime and
rampant corruption, the public’s faith in
the government has eroded over the years.
Their trust in congress, the presidency, the supreme court are all at an all time
low.
Meanwhile, the public’s view of the armed
forces is relatively favorable — with nearly
8 out of 10 Brazilians supporting the institution.
For Brazilians fed up with the political ruling
class, Jair Bolsonaro is offering an alternative.
But for many others, Bolsonaro's offensive comments
and anti-democratic solutions are a reminder
of Brazil's authoritarian past.